welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Rick and Morty season four is
back with episode six never Ricky Morty
an episode designed to make every social
media story structure analyzer feel
stupid you're 14 you watch videos of
people on YouTube reacting to YouTube
I'll be the judge when we get to
metaphor anyone who thought they had a
high enough IQ to keep up with this
runaway train of an episode welcome back
to Rick explained our cringy titled Rick
and Morty after-show where we do our
best to understand what the hell is
going on on this show along with some
special guests from it our
frame-by-frame breakdown of all the
hidden animation jokes is coming in a
separate video you know so that you can
feel like the story lord of our comment
sections which i'm sure you already are
because half of you [ __ ] comment on
this video before watching it to this
point
this episode is titled never Rick and
Morty a nod to the never Indian story a
film about a story within a story in
which the meta outer frame story layer
leaves the inner story with lesser
stakes aside from when they drown to gut
him horse in a swamp the Rick and Morty
writers wanted to explore an idea of an
anthology a collection of non-canonical
stories within a meta-narrative
but because this is Rick and Morty the
writers parody the very concept of
anthology by representing it as a
runaway train that Morty and Rick are
trapped on its evil conductor this story
Lord it's not a real train it's a story
device literally a literal literary
device quite literally metaphorically
containing us the way bong joon-ho used
a train as an allegory for a capitalist
society and snowpiercer the Rick and
Morty writers Jeff Lovelace this episode
the guy now writing a Man 3 for marvel
and a guru in every room he's in Dan
Harvin they use a train as an allegory
for the craft of storytelling the
writers themselves our narrative
adventurers trapped on a runaway story
train of a freewheeling tv-show trying
to regain control of it but failing and
eventually surrendering to that failure
I think it's gonna be a favorite episode
of mine but I'd be the first to say like
the story train itself it got away from
us to understand this episode it helps
to understand the difference between a
linear story and a circular story as
defined by Dan Harmon's story philosophy
Harmon is a follower of the philosopher
Joseph Campbell and he adapted
Campbell's story philosophy into the
famous Dan Harmon's story circle that
you've probably seen before it's broken
up into eight story beats and Harmons
obsession and discipline over this
circle has
helped make shows like Rick and Morty
and communities so great many sitcoms
are linear a predictable a to be trip
we're not much happens each episode but
good stories have curved their circular
taking hero's on full life's journeys
before returning them back to their
homes but with new thematic outlooks
Harmons circle even shows up in this
episode when Rick figures out what's
going on of course this thing is just a
circle you'd think it was so goddamn
complicated okay here's where the stupid
vignettes were got imagine if that had
been the whole thing so now we're here
and the engine must be here I'll have to
rig us a couple of space suits that
start failing around here so we could
pay a heavy price for re-entering at
this threshold those vignettes were in
step to need where the crisis and the
hero's goal is established dumb
anthology train Rick once off
Rick's joke about the vignettes being
the whole episode is the writers
snarking that other anime the show's
never progressed past 25% of what Rick
and Morty typically do you know for a
lot of shows that vignettes I heard
really all it is but now they're on step
3 titled go and which of the heroes
enter an unfamiliar situation aka where
Morty and Rick are now and they now use
the circle to foreshadow the rest of the
episode the complicated take step in
which the heroes pay a heavy price in
the engine room located that the final
change step where the hero transforms
his outlook each train car is a
different ontology meta storytelling
format stories from a bar Christmas
tales a VR game at blitz and chits we
move from car to car when the characters
step out of that meta format and reveal
it as a frame the air inside the Train
is breathable continuity the connective
tissue between these stories to keep
them all within a narrative but outside
the Train is narrative chaos rewarding
nothing up there is candid that includes
fanservice see Rick and Morty dream
pitches that remind us to never trust a
trailer a battle with evil Morty and
armies of meeseeks and gazorpazorp Ian's
the return of snowball and Tammy o
non-canon Rick's attempt to right the
Train is to try to fix it with a Bechtel
test the feminist criticism that some
storytellers find protective since its
rules alone don't make a good story
similarly dan harmon has admitted that
his early attempt to address feminism on
Ricky
morty the female dominated planet
gazorpazorp with his least favorite
episode the only way to truly stop the
train is the discovery that all hero's
journeys are at their core the story of
Christ and realizing that your story
that you think is so unique it's really
just a veggie tale that's a bummer
[Music]
anyone who has seen or done a crappy
improv show can attest bring it in Jesus
grinds everything to a halt and makes
you wish that instead of carrying you on
that beach it was burying you underneath
it this episode's final reveal the
change step shows that the victory is
merely taking place within another
meta-narrative device kind of like that
lame twist ending the saying elsewhere
it's all within a child's toy here Rick
delivers the episode's true cynical
message God loved money so much Morty
being sarcastic
merchandise Morty your only purpose in
life is to buy and consume merchandise
that twist filled curved journey on this
story train remains one trapped on a
track not in control of its own destiny
but repeating in endless loops it's
incapable of true change or synthesis
because it's objective it's just to make
money just like how the Rick and Morty
writers feel that despite their bold
innovative storytelling their sole
purpose is to sell merch for their media
company overlords at Adult Swim Turner
Broadcasting Warner and AT&T
merch is the true prophet of these
animated TV shows it's a sick endless
cycle of commerce that [ __ ] I'm part of
as bong joon-ho taught us and
snowpiercer the train is life and in
never Ricky Morty the Train is the life
of the writers an endless spiral of
unconstructed story ideas of pop culture
nods that all tied together into a
sophisticated but kind of hard to follow
critique of narrative itself an upward
coil or a snake eating its own tail or
just a vehicle for jokes about gutters
for tea groans most people call them
roast people I don't want to have to
picture I'm so watery and such volumes
that yeah I'm betting gutters will be
the pickle Rick mean we get from this
episode is this Rick's planation legit
or as you trash comforters conclude at
the moment you clicked on this video
this [ __ ] well let's bring into this
after show Chad a couple second opinions
join us now our Rick and Morty voice
actor and voice of mr. goldenfold
the Brandon Johnson thanks for coming
back man good to be here man
always excited to do the show hell yeah
and joining us also is Rick and Morty
superfan and according to his resume
former and future gutter
Tommy Bechtold welcome back and shredded
and then getting wedded baby let's go
let's go these gutters are ready to be
filled this train has already left the
station guys I feel like this episode
started with the premise that I
understood I had a good handle on it
but then it might have moved a bit too
fast for me in the middle it lost me but
then I found it again by the end which
maybe was the design of it I want to
know from you what what point do you
lose this train and at what point did
you feel like oh and I'm back on the
train I think for me I as soon as I gave
up trying to really follow it and I
started to just really enjoy the jokes
and the visual sight gags I kind of fell
back into following what was going on it
was one of those things were like you
can only like escape if you relax like
you relax your body like it was like I
had tried so hard I was thinking so hard
how to follow this episode and then the
second I gave up I was able to follow
what was going on and enjoy it so did
you say the only time that you can
escape is if you relax your body do that
they had like relaxed their risks to get
the ropes to slide off I have taken a
lot of people prisoner Brandon oh I'm
glad you're the one taking prisoner
rather than being taken prisoner
although I don't know if I'm actually
glad about I feel like every time the
three of us do this show I admit to some
sort of describe horrible you really do
we go for it cuz you're like and here
like that dad that gives advice but it's
crazy like hey man I hear those bullies
Abbas Bunny peasant like what you used
to do is counterfeit some money cuz I
was kind of treating money and then hand
out those counterfeit bills to those
kids that's my advice
cuz that bad estate advice you just gave
me I'm like we know too much with this
episode like I I don't know if you guys
felt this way it
seemed like the writers understood their
own structures so inherently in the way
they outlined these episodes that they
were moving so fast through it that they
were just kind of like expecting us to
to be along for that ride without giving
us any time to catch up with them which
I don't know I kind of appreciated like
my intelligence just being trusted how
do you guys feel about that it's
interesting because Rick and Morty is in
a unique position where they have to
laugh at themselves and they sort of
have to make sure that everybody knows
that they don't take it seriously
because that's their brand the thing is
is I'm not I'm not really I know my [ __ ]
smells so I feel like this season what
we've seen them doing is making fun of
anybody who thinks the show is God right
yeah I I definitely feel that way it's
like they were very aware of the fans
even more than usual this episode they
were teasing all these like dream plots
they're calling them non-canon we saw
like a return of an eat of a me Sikh
army of evil Morty there was this
lightsaber duel with Tammy and
birdperson was in a musical like these
are all like episodes that fans have
been like desiring for so long
which of these episodes do you feel the
most bummed to learn might not be an
episode now because it was teased here
the bird person musical being burned
like this really bummed me out
I was I was rooting for that one to come
on I think any sort of musical for them
I mean the saw the original songs that
they do like was it was a two seasons
ago they're the Jemaine Clement kind of
like Space Odyssey or star by Andy that
was so good like they're so they're
obviously so smart and so creative like
a song of an episode of all original
songs this season or next season would
be something I've really looked forward
to and I hope they did not burn that but
with the bird person musical it's
interesting that we burn all of the
potential X's that Rick might have and
it's only something that I pushed when I
was in the room for the brief amount of
time that I was in the groove I was like
is there not an X we can dig up because
sometimes you run out of story ideas in
you come into the room and you're like
okay so Morty has this and they're like
Canon are you like okay okay canon okay
well then Rick ghost and they're like
canon and sometimes maybe even do it so
so that they could save it for a later
season so I really feel like they
they've given it their best and they are
fishing but because it's a talented
writers they're great at catching fish
yeah you know it I love seeing them go
through these like alternate story
pitches cuz it feels like they're not
being Precious about anything they're
like yeah we know you want an evil Morty
return we got something better planned
like we're not just gonna give you
exactly what you want we're gonna give
you what we think stories need which is
like complexity and like philosophy and
spirituality and yeah we'll make some
jokes about like gutters which I have to
ask you guys about this because this
season we've seen shy pooping we've seen
like weird dragon sex orgies in that we
have this weird that it seems like the
writers are like yeah we're gonna do
some complex storytelling but we also
want to ask is this weird thing like
what what's going on here I like let's
let's go into the into the ditch here
what what gross stuff do we want to see
explored next or do we think they're
gonna ask next I actually think that
like what they're what they're doing in
my opinion is they're kind of parodying
the way our culture now has become
almost idiocracy like obsessed with poop
in stand and like profanity like if you
think about like little kids there's
more like poop themed toys for little
kids in the aisles of Target and Walmart
then there's ever been but then they go
into the my special time story line to
pass the Bechdel test they're gonna they
do the like most safe unoffensive period
be period themed like little vignette
that they could possibly do like
basically being like we have no idea how
to write for women we have no instead of
just being raunchy overly gross men
we're just gonna act like be completely
oblivious to how this all works so I
think it's kind of like the the fact
that it's on even a little dirtier this
year is more of a like
almost kind of a like comment on society
being like we've all gone a little bluer
but we can still be smart about it yeah
well so you've got two teenage boys that
created the show you knew damn well the
titty twister is the next sure just
watch that Justin roiland cartoon from
the hilarity for charity special and
that's all you need to know have you
ever seen that what is the charity
brothers I'm a fan of I'm a bigger fan
of mr. spring keys that's a door that's
a good eye
I also love that they nodded to be a
massive amount of merchandising that the
show is responsible for I mean you can
buy any sort of toy any sort of blanket
in the Rick and my office's when you
walk in there's stacks and stacks and
stacks of things that you would never
think they give licensing for like there
is a pickle pickle Rick yeah oh my god
like that's I it's kind of sad and
cynical that that's the station they
arrived at at the end of the episode but
like I can imagine those riders feeling
that's the darkest truth of this show
that like no matter what they think this
show is actually a vehicle for for like
philosophy or science fiction
exploration or comedy it's actually like
its biggest impact on society might be
that it's just a vehicle to sell toys
clothes merch and like ultimately that's
how their overlords see this show is
this has been the most profitable thing
for many of these people's careers is
just to show that like they're able to
sell anything in association with Rick
and Morty I always try to tell actors
when they talk about how much they love
their career and the craft and all these
things I always say remember that you're
here so people didn't have sex they need
a darkness they need a dark room to sit
in two hours to contemplate how they're
gonna make their move and then once they
learn leave once they leave the movie
that's the get down and at the same
thing with a comedy club is like they
come to the comedy club they drink they
sit next to each other they laugh
show each other their teeth then they
leave and have sex so you can't really
be precious with what we do it's a point
that every artist eventually arrives at
like I feel like you know Warhol Picasso
all these guys eventually like oh wait
my final stage of evolution is realizing
that I'm just here to make money for
people and then like artists like Banksy
are like they've turned that into their
entire identity of like you people are
trying to sell my art you try to sell my
art at an auction I'm gonna shred it the
moment there's a purchaser for it and I
feel like that's a Rick and Morty is
doing now they're like all right you're
gonna try to sell this we're gonna make
this the most disgusting thing that you
try to sell we're gonna talk about
gutters and episode we're gonna talk
about snide pooping we're just gonna
make the show we want and you still have
to sell it AT&T this is what you're now
trying to sell the kids have fun we work
out culture just to insult every person
in shape I was wracking by the artists
when they were drawing this episode and
they pulled me over and and they were
like look at this I was with Nick
Rutherford we were coming back in the
kitchen and we looked at Jesus with the
insane butters and I looked at him and I
said man if only I had enough to fill
those gutters he put his arms around me
and he said let's get you back into the
writers Jesus can help you he could turn
just a little enough to fill the
greatest of gutters that's also a really
interesting part of this is that
loveness was raised very religious and
this is I was gonna say yeah and this is
his episode you remember yeah you worked
with loveness at Kimmel right Tommy
mm-hmm so you know this about him too is
that he comes from they're not
fundamentalist I don't think I think
they're just I think they're just
religious I think and he went to Bible
Camp and kid so I really like that he
was able to incorporate that into the
episode and and I think at least that's
what you should do if you've had to be
religious or anyway
I think it does it smartly too it's like
you know it's obviously ridiculous and
it's a um you know it's obviously
pointing to the kind of hypocrisy and
strangeness of religion but it's not
taking the easy obvious shots at it that
have been taken for you know since since
movies and TV have been around it's
almost like a like it's more taking
shots at the people who continue to say
this stuff in that you know like it's
it's not poking fun at Jesus it's poking
fun at the idea that Jesus is a
sixth-floor white guy who weighs 185
pounds and like hasn't eaten a carbon in
31 of his 32 years it's a great concern
once a week when he eats his own body I
like the idea but he's also [ __ ] on
the people who wrote the Bible as a
fellow writer he's like yes I would like
Geoff to write a Bible I'd be fine with
that yeah what would you put in your
Bible my Bible
mostly recipes apple crumble recipes
basically pie base desserts you know
that's an interpretation of the Bible
that we haven't dug into yet I feel like
if you read every other word you're
gonna find a recipe for well I guess
cannibalism right isn't that what that's
one take
I think microbreweries there's like
certainly a small batch distillery
option there with the wine guys this
whole episode of her explained has gone
through those stages of story evolution
right like we went to the darkest depths
of talking about cutters and now we've
evolved to the final station of like
Christ has arrived he's come again to to
bring us back to morality thank God
I can't old you ever never ever read to
me I like a good Catholic I don't read
it I just have someone explain to me
what it is now that's what I do don't
watch these episodes of TV just have me
yell at you what it means that's that's
what this is all about
no one consumes people consume the
consumption oh boy Wow guys this has
been a fascinating episode I want to
thank our guests up
Brandon Johnson for coming back to the
show it's awesome having you back so
good to be here thank you so much great
to see you guys
amidst all the cast that's in the world
hell yeah and thanks as always to Tommy
back told what won't entrap you and get
you arrested eventually reminder to all
of you watching you could get early
audio versions of the show by
subscribing to the Rix playing podcast
where we get your podcasts you can
follow me on social media following
rockstars subscribe to this channel for
more Rick and Morty coverage reminder
that our breakdown of all the hidden
animation details that chokes Easter
eggs that's gonna be a separate video
it's coming out next and we'll close out
this week on our favorite joke this
episode roll the clip
I guess I'll return in a turn are you
insane did you hear nothing I said buy
another one Morty consume Morty nobody's
out there shopping with this virus
where's your wallet
[Music]